And we're going to do a strategy that we've done before. Let's look at a simpler
version of the problem. A pair of shoes costs $60 and is on sale for 20% off.
What will you pay for the shoes? The key thing is that we do not pay 100% of the
price. If we did pay 100% of the price, our math would look like this. We'd have
$60 times 100%.
I know percent means out of 100. So, I have 60 times 100 over 100. Well, I know
100 of our 100 is just 1, so I have 60 times 1. I could have just gotten that by
moving my decimal two places to the left. We know dividing by 100 is the same
thing as moving the decimal two places left. So, I would owe $60. Notice, if you
have 100% of something, the value doesn't change. My price originally was $60,
and if I pay 100%, I still pay $60.